Thank you.
Welcome to the October 7th meeting of the Science, Technology and Energy Committee.
We will start a work session on five interim study bills in just a moment.
But first, as is our custom, let's all rise and join Representative McGee as she leads us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation of their God, indivisibleible with liberty and justice for all.
So, ST&E retained five bills for interim study in its 2024 session, the earlier part of our session.
And so, we have to pass judgment on what to do with those five bills.
Now we have two choices.
One is we can judge that a bill is recommended for future legislation, or two, we can recommend that it's not recommended for future legislation.
Now, whichever one of those recommendations we make are not actually binding.
A legislator could file a bill, even if the interim study bill on which his bill was based, his or her bill was based, was judged to be not recommended.
Likewise, someone, even if a bill is recommended for future legislation, that doesn't require someone to file it.
And in fact, it may never get filed as a result of that recommendation.
So these recommendations are not binding, but they are just guiding.
They provide guidance for future legislators to decide, well, let's see, if I want to file a bill based on this and it was recommended for future legislation, I might have better luck getting it through the legislature than if it was not recommended for future legislation.
So it's basically a guide for the future.
So with that said, are there any questions or comments about the process here this morning?
What I would like to do is just go through each bill in the order that they're listed in the calendar and have a discussion about whether the bill has any pros or any cons.
Just get a sense of what people would like to do.
We're not going to vote on bills this morning.
We're going to wait until one o'clock this afternoon to do that.
But I would like everybody to chime in and give us your thoughts and your feelings about each bill.
The one thing that we do have to supply at the end of the day today is a report on each of these bills.
Whether we recommend for future legislation or not recommend for future legislation, we have to have a two, three, four sentence report that can be published in the House calendar about each bill.
That's to satisfy one of our House rules that says that every bill submitted to the legislature gets a fair hearing and is subject to the judgment of the general court.
So this is basically a fulfillment of that requirement.
We have given the bill a fair hearing and we have determined either to recommend or not recommend it.
So with that prelude, let's jump right in.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to announce the number of the bill and read its title.
And then I'm going to turn it over to our House clerk, who, as you will recall, took extensive notes about each bill when we heard it originally.
And he's going to read the, what did you call it?
Statement of intent for each bill, so that we will know just exactly what the bill was intended for.
So we'll start with...
for each bill so that we will know just exactly what the bill was intended for.
So we'll start with House Bill 509 relative to the phasing out of the minimum electric renewable portfolio standard.
So Mr.
Clerk, let's hear the statement of intent.
The future of the renewable portfolio standard remains ambiguous beyond 2025.
Should it be retained or eliminated?
How long does a program need to be in place for it to be considered effective?
What constitutes effectiveness for such programs?
These kinds of questions need further analysis that a referral to an interim study provides.
Okay, so that's why we referred this bill to interim study.
We could choose to debate the questions in the statement of intent, or we could just choose to make a judgment about what to do with the bill today.
I personally would prefer the latter, to make a judgment on what to do with the bill today.
But if there is an intense desire to study the bill, we could do that for a couple of weeks before we have to finish it and wrap up our recommendation.
So I'd like to hear from the members about what their feelings might be.
Representative Arrington.
Yeah.
I mean, let's just start with a little bit of history here.
It's been, I don't know how many years.
I think Al Gore made his famous speech about the end of the world coming in 10 years.
That was about 16, 17 years ago, and the world hasn't ended.
So everybody's been inundated with global warming, climate change.
Nobody in New Hampshire, unless they're literally living underground someplace, is unaware of all the information available on climate change.
Given that, I don't think beyond 2025, we should make the assumption that the people of New Hampshire are too ignorant to make a decision on what type of electricity to buy.
They can buy whatever they want, and we should allow them the freedom to make that decision for themselves.
A little more historical thing, people may or may not know, there's actually a law on the books that says utilities must provide up to 100% renewable energy if requested by a customer, and the customer has to pay any additional costs associated with that.
That law was suspended.
There was provision to suspend it if there was lack of participation.
When the law was in effect, 0.2%, that 0.2% of people opted to pay extra to get renewable energy.
Now, subsequent to that, there's been more available options for competitive suppliers, some of which provide all wind energy or whatever.
So there's really no need for the state to say, you're not smart enough to make a decision for yourself.
We're going to force you to buy the right type of electricity.
This is simply a matter of freedom.
No one out there is ignorant.
No one can say, well, they don't know anything about the need for renewable energy because we constantly get bombarded with that information.
It's everywhere you turn.
So I think it's time to tell the people of New Hampshire, yes, we recognize you're intelligent enough to make a decision on what type of electricity to buy.
Just like we say, we don't say, well, you have to buy a certain percentage of your produce must be organically grown because it's healthier for you.
Or a certain percentage of the milk you buy must be skim milk because that's healthier for you.
We let these people make their own decisions.
They can do it with electricity as well.
Okay.
Question for you, Representative Harrington.
Was the phase out of the original bill a five-year phase out?
Is that what you recommended?
Yeah, I believe it was because even though I don't think anybody that gets government subsidies has a right to those subsidies, but in trying to be a little bit fairer, it would be if you were getting the subsidies now, this phase out would allow you to make plans for the future so you could market yourself to people just the way other products do rather than lobbying at the state house for additional subsidies.
So that was the purpose of the five-year phase-out.
Was there any provision in the bill for grandfathering people who had installed renewable energy based on the provisions of the program earlier?
No.
Again, anybody that receives a subsidy from the government should not say, well, since you're giving me $20 for a subsidy, forcing to take it from the rate payers and giving it to me, you don't have a right to continue to get that forever.
There was never any commitment.
There was never anything in the bill that said, okay, if you put in renewable energy and you qualify for the RPS, we will pay you forever on it.
That was never stated.
In fact, the bill had a phase-out time, built with it, 2025.
And I think that this is even a little bit more generous than that.
But again, because you're getting a subsidy doesn't mean you have a right to the subsidy.
That's a decision that can be made.
It can be granted and be taken away by the state.
And the bill did restore the requirement that the utilities offer 100% renewable resource-generated power if customers wanted that?
Yes, I believe that was in there.
It just basically, what happened was the utilities jointly petitioned the PUC.
I was on the commission at the time, and they brought forward that the administrative costs of that particular program where people could request up to the 100% renewable energy, that was borne by the ratepayers, not by the people who selected the renewable energy.
Any additional cost associated with the procurement of the renewable energy was borne by the person who requested it.
But they came forward to us and said, look, 0.2% of the people are requesting this.
The administrative costs are so high, and we can't justify them based on the small participation rate.
And since the law allow the PUC to suspend it, it was suspended.
Okay.
Additional...
them based on this small participation rate.
And since the law allowed the PUC to suspend it, it was suspended.
Okay.
Additional comments about this.
Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So my understanding is the renewable portfolio standards came into being as a way for the state to sort of keep track of how we were doing in terms of adoption of local sustainable, cleaner sources of energy.
And that was in part because we had plans we were trying to make available to businesses and to individuals about how the state was addressing the need to lower our emissions and dependence on fossil fuels.
So the Renewable Portfolio Standard, as it stands, as I think the chairman alluded to, the program provides price signals in the market for various categories of energy, including hydro.
There are a number of impacts that would happen from this phase out to the economics of clean energy sources that we have in the state.
And that's the reason that I would probably, on this bill, I would vote not to recommend that it go forward because I think there is a lot more of an analysis about what the impact is to people who have made plans around the fact that the state has an RPS.
And I realize that additional legislation is likely to come because we have an end date on the existing RPS statute of 2025, with a goal of 25% of our energy being from renewable sources.
So I think we do need to address this issue.
But I think this concept of phasing it out without analyzing what that will do to the markets and what that will do to businesses and what that will do to people who are operating clean energy operations in New Hampshire.
I don't think we want to disincentivize them either.
So I don't feel there's been enough information on the economics of the effects of what would happen if we decided to phase the program out.
So that's what I think.
Okay.
Additional comments.
Representative Kaplan.
Yeah, I just want to thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just want to concur with Representative McGee.
I think that going forward with this bill without an analysis would be foolhardy in terms of the economic impact on the state and the businesses that are already involved in the clean energy transition.
But I also think that we need to look at the purpose of the RPS, which is to bring on more clean energy in order to transition us away from our dependence on fossil fuels because of the impact of burning fossil fuels on the climate.
That's a very real thing.
And to question that is, you know, is to deny the science, the consensus on the need to do that in order to, you know, save us from the worst impacts of climate change.
So I just wanted to mention that.
Okay.
Additional comments?
Representative Reynolds.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just want to chime in and support my ranking member and my fellow member, Representative Kaplan.
The Renewable Portfolio Standard is longstanding public policy.
New Hampshire's one of something like 34, 35, two-thirds of states in the United States have one.
It's public policy, prudent policy to diversify this state's energy resources.
New Hampshire has no native fossil fuels.
The only native energy sources we have are renewable sources.
And so we should do nothing to reduce incentives and support for further development of renewable energy resources because they strengthen the state economically.
So I also would not support moving this bill forward.
Representative McWilliams, nice to see you.
Good to see you as well.
Thank you, Chair Boz.
I just wanted to make a quick comment that we have existing biomass facilities that are both county and state-owned that would be impacted by the removal of the RPS because of their biomass right now.
That is a business impact on what we're concerned about, big picture, federal, state, and local county-owned facilities that right now are benefiting from the RPS.
And we really should look at that, I think, in a little bit more granularity before just pulling the rug out from underneath those business cases.
Thank you.
Representative Harrington.
Yeah, just a couple of quick replies to that.
First, obviously, any company that's getting a subsidy from ratepayers or taxpayers is going to complain when the subsidy goes away.
That doesn't mean it should be perpetual.
This was set with an end limit to allow renewable energy to grow and to educate the people on the need for that, both of which have happened.
Thank you.
it should be perpetual.
This was set with an end limit to allow renewable energy to grow and to educate the people on the need for that, both of which have happened.
We cannot just go on forever with the subsidies.
It's response to what counties may have something of doing this.
Well, the people in my county shouldn't have to pay higher electric rates to subsidize some other county.
It's simply not their responsibility.
Let the county pay for their own cost.
The other part about this is we talk about, you know, our renewable energy in the state, we don't have any fossil fuels.
Well, the switch from coal and oil to natural gas accounted for almost 95% of the reduction in carbon dioxide emissions in New England over the last 10 or 15 years.
So using natural gas is a much cleaner source that we should be looking at making that happen with more pipelines or at least getting rid of the Jones Act so we can get an LNG from the United States.
But the renewable energy source we want to look at, as Luke mentioned, wood, well, we just, there was a settlement just made, maybe you're aware of this, but the biomass plant in Berlin went bankrupt because they could not get another, I think it would have been their third extension for not having to live up to the terms of the contract that they not only signed, but they pursued with Eversource that was public service then.
Now, that bankruptcy left the ratepayers owed $160 million.
So this is what happens when the government gets involved in the markets and tries to artificially set prices.
It's $160 million that the ratepayers paid to that biomass facility that they're never going to see back again.
And you might also know, how did they use some of that $160 million that they were paid over market rates?
They hired very expensive lobbyists to come down here to lobby for more ratepayer subsidies.
So basically, that bill forced the ratepayers to pay for people to raise the subsidies that they were paying.
That's what happens when the government interferes with markets.
We had a plan, ended in 2025.
Everybody knows about renewable energy.
Anyone can go out and buy it if they want to.
There's nothing that stops them from doing it.
It's available.
Just look on the internet under the PUC.
There's simply no need to extend this subsidy forever.
Who's next?
Representative Korman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Reynolds said something that I was thinking at that moment, which is actually harking back to something that you had been pointing out and advocating, Mr.
Chairman, and that's New Hampshire energy independence.
And we don't produce the fossil fuels.
We don't produce coal, oil, natural gas.
If we are going to move toward energy independence, it's going to have to be with renewable energy that we produce in state.
So I think we should be supporting it.
Another possibility there might be small modular nuclear.
So that's something we should keep in mind.
We get regular reports every year.
I'm sure every member of this committee gets them in their email inbox from the Department of Energy tracking the previous year's implementation of the RPS.
So we know how much it costs.
And we also, individually, I'm sure, get completed.
tracking the previous year's implementation of the RPS.
So we know how much it costs.
And we also individually, I'm sure, get complaints from constituents about the high cost of electricity.
And the RPS, according to the reports we get every year, costs ratepayers something like $55 million, $60 million every year.
And phasing out the RPS would be something that I think ratepayers would be in favor of because it would lower their electric costs.
So that's something to keep in mind as well.
Further comments on this bill?
Representative Kaplan?
Yeah.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I think that's a good point.
And as Representative McGee pointed out, the RPS is slated to end in 2025.
And so I think, I don't know if we can do this as a recommendation, but I think a study committee on the future of the RPS would be a good idea.
Actually, my reading of the legislation on RSA 362F indicates that it doesn't actually end in 2025.
It just does not go beyond 2025 in terms of increasing the amounts of renewable energy required.
It basically levels off at 25% and then stays there.
It doesn't increase or decrease.
And I think part of what Representative Harrington was driving at with the submission of this bill was rather than leave it be level, maybe it's time to start tapering it off.
And that Representative Kaplan might be a good subject to look at in a study committee regarding the future of the RPS.
Another question that the statement of intent that Representative Bernardi read to us a little while ago said that it's important for programs like this that we try to make a judgment about whether it's been effective or not.
Did it work?
Did it do what we wanted it to do?
And that might be the subject for some study of the RPS to determine, did it really do accomplish what we wanted it to accomplish.
It was passed back in 2007.
I think it went into effect around 2008.
So we have a pretty good period of time by which we could evaluate its success or failure.
Representative Harrington.
Yeah, I think the easiest way to do that, I don't have the figures in front of me, but the easiest way to determine if it was a success or a failure was to look at the alternate compliance payments.
How high are they?
They continue to go down.
I mean, the goal of the program was to put the alternate compliance payments at zero.
As you said, this has now been, I don't know, 15, 20 years or something like that.
And over that amount of time, with this amount of incentive, you would have thought if the market was there, that the alternate compliance payments would have gone to zero.
I don't think they have.
I don't know what they are.
But if you want to know the effectiveness of it, compare how much is actually generating renewable electricity and how much is going to alternate compliance payments to be distributed out as a form of more subsidies.
Representative McGee?
I'd love to try and put a cap on this.
Okay, what strikes me is that we're talking about a lot of different things that we all feel and think.
I think part of the goal of the RPS was to have a review of whether or not we were also lowering emissions by adopting additional clean energy sources.
We're not all aligned on this committee that we would be looking at that as an outcome or a goal.
So rather than do that, maybe let's get back to the business at hand, which is, do we recommend this for further legislation or are we not going to recommend it for further legislation?
Because I think we've talked about our perspective on all of the issues Thank you.
do we recommend this for further legislation or are we not going to recommend it for further legislation?
Because I think we've talked about our perspective on all of the issues.
Well, I don't think we have to make that call now.
We'll make that call in executive session.
What I wanted to do here is just have a good discussion.
Representative Bernardi?
yes mr chairman we We do need a vote on whatever motion we're going to take.
It's not the binding vote of the executive session, but it's a vote on the motion.
At least by the force.
So somebody needs to make a motion?
Is that what you're saying?
We need to make a motion on either recommend for future legislation or not recommend.
That needs to be seconded and we need a vote.
I'd like to make a motion then.
I'd like to make a motion that we not recommend this bill for the legislation.
Is there a second?
Second.
Okay.
There's a couple of them.
So now, can we do this by voice vote or raising hands?
Do we have to do a roll call?
Mr.
Chairman, point of order.
Yes.
I'm not sure what we're doing.
I mean, this is not an executive session.
No, it isn't.
But we have a form here.
You're welcome to look at it it it says subcommittee work session on hb 509 i should put my glasses on and then it um it has a motion section and it apparently wants us to vote now i i didn't know that this was a requirement of a work session.
I guess my question would be, if we're going to vote on this now, what are we going to be voting on in the executive session?
Well, I was told that this vote is not binding.
So I guess it's a straw vote.
That's why I think we could do it by raising hands rather than a roll call.
So it's basically just a straw vote.
So on the motion of not recommended for future legislation, all those in favor, raise your hand.
10.
Okay, so there's 10 that vote in favor of that motion.
And all those opposed, raise your hand.
One, two, three, four.
Four that are opposed.
So 10 to four, but it's not binding.
So we'll do it again during executive session.
Okay, let's move on.
Next is House Bill 1398, relative to utility recovery of costs associated with net energy metering.
So Mr.
Clerk, please read us the statement of intent on House Bill 1398.
This bill sought to extend net metering cost recovery mechanism called stranded cost recovery used by the state's largest utility to New Hampshire's other regulated utilities.
This extension was envisioned to provide trackability and transparency to net metering costs and to ensure that all customers paid those charges, not just default service customers.
The committee amended the bill to specify that the mechanism could be any non-bypassable charge if that charge appeared on the customer's bill, but the amended bill stalemated 10 to 10.
Subsequent deliberations centered around testimony that purported to claim that alternative energy suppliers and aggregators would be competitively disadvantaged by the bill's passage.
But this alleged disadvantage exists today because regulated utilities contest the notion that load settlement for net metering costs should include wholesale load reductions and or avoided transmission costs.
Utilities believe that such reductions cannot be captured with current ISO New England load settlement protocols and metering.
State regulators are currently engaged in this complicated debate, so the committee ultimately decided that the bill and its subject matter be deferred for more study and future resolution.
So I'm now becoming aware that the statement of intent is basically the calendar report for a bill.
Is that true?
I believe so.
Yes.
Okay.
So, obviously, the bill as introduced to the committee had the intent of having all the utilities, not just Eversource, recover net metering costs through stranded cost recovery.
It was no more complicated than that.
But the subject matter of recovering net metering costs itself is complicated, as we all well know.
And the idea that load settlement should be part of this, I think, will probably be the subject of at least one bill that we'll see this coming session.
So this subject will be addressed and probably would obviate the need for this bill by itself to go forward.
There may be another version of this bill that comes along.
Who knows?
Any further discussion on this bill?
Representative Harrington.
Given what you just said, I'd like to make a motion that it's not for further legislation.
Okay, second on that motion?
Okay, it's seconded.
Any further discussion before we take a straw vote on this?
Who seconded?
Representative McGee.
Any further discussion before we take a straw vote?
All those in favor of not recommending this bill for future legislation, raise your hand.
Any opposed?
That's a unanimous vote.
Yep.
We can't count Doug because he walked in.
So our vice chair, Representative Thomas, is here.
And by the way, I forgot to welcome Representatives Horrigan and Gallagher, who are going to be sitting in during the executive session later today.
All right, so now let's move on to House Bill 1508, requiring fiber optic communication service providers to prioritize service restoration for public safety and public health organizations.
And I recognize the clerk to read the statement of intent.
This bill requires that a provider of communication services prioritize restoration of communications for critical infrastructure over commercial and residential customers.
An issue prescribing restoration prioritization in law is that it could hinder or slow down efficient restoration for all customers.
Interim study would allow the committee to investigate alternative solutions and to better understand the issues faced by public safety and health agencies and working with communication service providers to resource service.
The prime sponsor agreed to refer to this bill to interim study.
Okay, Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just wanted to let you know that the prime sponsor of this bill is from the north country um it's uh representative linda massamilla and she called me over the weekend because she put in the bill it originated from the chief of police in littleton who asked her um to bring this to the's attention.
And he was asking her whether he should come down and attend our work session.
And I waved her off and I said, no, it won't, that won't be worth his time.
But she did ask me to bring the recommendation that it go forward.
So that I think she wants to put it in again, but she just asked if we could, if we would consider making a recommendation that it's a worthy bill.
So do we want to actually study this bill before we make a recommendation or do we just want to go forward with a recommendation?
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I would just like to make a statement because this bill was, I kind of took this bill and pressed to have it put into interim study at the time.
What I got from the bill and from the public testimony was that we're in kind of a dichotomy here.
We're dealing with a private company that apparently was unresponsive for a significant period of time, according to the police of Chalief, the chief of police.
And the quandary was that he had no one to turn to.
He tried to contact state officials and they said, sorry, private company, not our bailiwick.
And so what he was left with was really no point of contact.
And so he was left hanging for a couple of months at least before he could get his communications back up to speed.
I find that unacceptable.
And quite frankly, if that private company was here right now i would admonish them for for their lack of speed in in trying to correct the situation that that was very important to our first responders at the same time according to testimony uh it would be very difficult to try and put a bill together that would require some state agency to respond to something like this that we heard.
I still feel that we're left in a vacuum here.
A private company dealing with a very significant resource like communications for a first responder apparently has no one to turn to if the private company decides, oh, we'll get to you in a couple of months.
I don't know what the answer is right now.
I would welcome a bill, maybe differently written, but maybe more to the point of that we might want to study next time.
But at the same time, I'm asking myself, how do we require something to be handled by the state when a private company is involved?
I really don't know the answer to that, but I do know the problem exists.
Should it happen again, who does it turn to?
Who does the person turn to to get relief?
If not to the company's CEO, and if they're unresponsive, what happens next?
We're dealing with the first responder here.
That's my question.
That's the quandary I have.
Representative Munns had his hand up first, if that's okay.
Representative McGee, go ahead.
Thank you.
The bill isn't for the state agencies.
It's for the provider of the communication service, right?
So it's basically saying, let's change the rules to make sure that those people who are providing communication services prioritize, you know, emergency first responders and public safety apparatus when they are reinstating.
So that's what the bill was trying to do was just say, if you're in this business of you're responsible for those communication lines, then you have to put those public safety agencies first in line when you're restoring an area, an area's power.
So that's what they were trying to get at.
And so that's what it says, a provider of communication services, right?
So I think the question of whether we can force them to do that, I mean, I think they maybe probably should already be doing that because those communication services are essential.
Right.
To trying to get the rest of it up and going.
But but anyway, what we're just deciding whether we recommend that it should go forward, not that we have to do it, but just recommend whether it should go forward for further review or not.
We're not trying to solve it here today.
Although it is true, if you look at the substance of the bill, that it is a weak bill in the sense that it doesn't actually specify that where in the queue these public safety and public health organizations should be moved.
It also has no enforcement mechanism.
So it's a pretty weak bill from that point of view.
And while the problem is a serious problem, as you and Representative Thomas have both indicated, I'm not sure that this is the proper solution, but maybe there is a solution that might come forward.
Representative Summers, you had your hand up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just to add some knowledge to this, after looking at this bill, and myself owning a network engineering company that does telecommunications services, FiberNet.
This bill is actually too generalized to even be able to push forward, being that a lot of the first responders, state-run, state facilities, and municipalities, even like hospitals and such, have to fit under what's called an E-rate, which falls under different licensing and time constraints.
They have permits they have to require.
So it would be impossible for these facilities to be able to wait the amount of time for all of these permits, E-rate, and that to pass to meet also the budget time frame for them and to put all their other commercial and residential customers on hold while you're waiting for all of this to put them forward.
So there's just no way to do that.
So you don't think this bill is strong enough?
I don't think it's strong enough.
I don't think it's worded correctly, and I don't think it meets, doesn't define exactly what they're looking to do.
Representative Harrington.
You follow up on that.
One of the problems I see with this is I'm not sure the state even has jurisdiction over Internet.
I know the PUC doesn't.
And it's the issue there is the FCC has the federal authority over that.
So I'm not sure we have the ability to order a private internet company to do anything other than like with citing laws and where they put their wires on poles and such.
But as to how they run their business, I would think we should probably check with the attorney general's office or something like that and determine if we even have the authority to do it.
And second of all, I don't know the Littleton police chief at all, but I would think the best way to address this, if I was a police chief somewhere, is I would contact the cable company or the internet company or wherever you're getting your service from on a non-crisis time and get a contact.
I'm quite sure that if you got in touch with someone there, which isn't always the easiest thing to do, that they would be responsive.
I know that the one that serves most of my district, I have a cell phone number for the guy and I can call him basically 24-7 and he gets back to me right away.
So even though there's no regulatory authority, he does understand I'm a state representative and if someone has a problem, I can call him on it and try to get it straightened out.
So I think there are other alternatives.
But before we try to pass a feel good law, which this is kind of written as because it's going to have a lot more detail, you have to have some enforcement.
Who what defines these first responders?
There's no definition.
I think we should first find out, do we have the authority to even enforce anything on them?
And that's a legal question, which I simply can't answer.
Representative Corman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
First thing I want to say is put your money on the Patriots for Sunday, because I agree with what Representative Harrington just said.
I'd add a couple of things.
One is this bill is only about fiber optic communications.
There's lots of other ways of communications, and this bill doesn't even cover it.
It also seems to me that a municipal first responder or whatever this is trying to cover really should have a backup system in case the fiber goes down.
I mean, I think this is partly on the organization for not planning to have a backup system.
Good point.
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
If I remember correctly during public testimony, there were some extenuating circumstances as to the good representative's point there.
I believe the police chief was informed that there was going to be work done during that period and that there would be no disruption in service to speak of, and it turned out that wasn't true.
So perhaps he was led to believe that there wouldn't be a major delay when in fact there was.
So perhaps that might have some circumstances as to how they got into the situation.
The point I want to make is that what we're talking about now is not the merits of this bill, but whether or not the idea that further legislation may want to be introduced in the future.
And to Representative Summers' point, a bill that might be more specific or more to the point of what we're trying to do.
So I just want to make that clarification.
Representative Munns.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
My recollection from the hearing was that when all was said and done, this boiled down to a customer service issue.
And I don't know how you can legislate good customer service.
Because to Representative Harrington's point, because if we could, boy, there's a lot of areas where we could address.
So that's, I mean, I understand what Representative Thomas is saying in terms of, you know, the need for first responders to be able to get their service restored, but I just, I'm struggling with how do you do that?
How do you address a customer service issue?
You're absolutely right about that.
As we learned when we discovered all of the customer service issues in the propane industry, right?
Okay, further comments.
Representative Ploge.
Thank you, Chair.
During testimony, Department of Energy, Mr.
Robridge, was opposed to this bill.
So, Representative Doug Thomas asked him, does the companies prioritize first responders?
And the Department of Energy came back and said, yes, they do prioritize.
And elsewhere in my notes, I said to myself that this was an issue that fell between the cracks.
Anybody have a motion about what to do with this bill?
Representative McGee.
Yeah, I'll make the recommendation that we do recommend some further legislation on this topic.
okay if we forward with that, would you be willing to write the report and point out the weaknesses of this?
Oh, that's a bridge too far.
All right, do we have a second to that motion?
Representative Thomas seconds the motion, so we'll take a straw straw vote All those in favor of asking that this Subject matter anyway be recommended for future legislation Raise your hand Any opposed?
Three opposed, four opposed, sorry Five, remember, this is a non-binding straw vote, so you can change your mind between now and exec session if you want.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, let's move on to the next bill.
Mr.
Chairman, one question, please.
Excuse me.
Yes.
Perhaps Representative Harrington.
Is there a mechanism, I don't know if there's a formal one, that we could make, ask the Attorney General's office for, does the state have authority to regulate anything having to do with Internet or cable?
because I know it, I thought when I was on the commission that it was pretty clear that those items were not because when we had the telephone situation, when we went to voice over IP, that became FCC only and the state had no longer, no authority.
So Representative Summers?
I can answer that.
So it's all FCC.
It all requires a license, 498, 499, and even to get an E-rate, it's all FCC related.
So state has nothing.
All right, let's move on.
House Bill 1617FN relative to energy procurement agreements for default service.
Mr.
Clerk, please read the statement of intent.
This bill commits Science, Tech, and Energy Committee to study the process of setting default service rates.
The concerns to be studied include enhancing price stability and lessening the impact of rate hikes caused by spikes in natural gas prices as these magnify the risk premium in the rates.
The committee agreed to do this in a manner that would not create a straight jacket for the New Hampshire Public Utilities Commission, but rather allow them flexibility in assuring reasonable price stability.
So it is my recollection that the PUC essentially took over this study and has been doing it themselves.
So I think our committee isn't really committed to studying this any further.
Representative Thomas.
I would agree.
Any other comments on this bill?
Representative Harrington.
Only that rate making is an incredibly involved, complicated process that takes months and months.
This committee would have to do nothing for the next couple of months if we wanted to start setting rates.
And I don't know if we have the expertise to even do it.
Correct.
Representative Corman.
My notes from the work session we had back in January also said something about that we had asked Commissioner Elms whether DOE would be able to model this and that we were supposed to be getting a report from them.
I don't recall that we got this report.
I do not recall seeing such a report either, but I can double back and check with Commissioner Elms to see if...
You need the other one.
Yes, that's true.
Commissioner Elms is on paternity leave for some period of time, but I'm sure someone at the department will be filling in for him, so I'll contact them.
Representative McGee.
I'd like to agree with everything that's been said and make a recommendation not to recommend this bill for further legislation.
Is there a second to that motion?
Yes.
So take a straw vote on this.
Who is second?
Representative Thomas.
Straw vote on this.
Everybody who would like to vote to not recommend this bill for future legislation, raise your hand.
Anybody opposed?
Looks unanimous.
All right, now let's tackle the final bill on our list, which is Senate Bill 540, which requires the Department of Energy to investigate behind the meter and utility scale energy storage.
So, Mr.
Clerk, if you could read to us the statement of intent.
This bill would study battery storage technologies for both customer and utility scale supply.
Utility scale supply is a province of Iceland in new england and therefore not a legitimate function of the department of energy the value of understanding a customers behind the meter storage is unknown and may or not be worth investigating interim study will assess that value okay looking at my notes on this legislation, it appears to be quite vague.
For example, on line 14 of the first page of the bill, it says, there's text that says, how to best encourage both utility and non-utility investments in energy storage projects.
Encourage is a pretty vague word.
This bill would cost about $250,000 to ratepayers.
Utility scale storage is an ISO New England concern.
Primary hurdles are financing and materials.
And those are not issues that require study.
Those are just fundamental issues to building batteries.
It's not government's job to encourage investments in battery storage.
Somebody else has to do that.
Somebody has to own these things.
And as I indicated initially, the requirements of the study are just too vague.
And another thing that's not acknowledged in this bill is that one of the major hurdles to utility-scale battery storage is the fact that it costs a lot of money to build these things, and they sit idle for long periods of time.
And that makes their financing extremely difficult.
And I don't know how to overcome that.
So I think this bill doesn't do the job of creating a study that can answer the question.
So I think I would recommend we don't recommend this for further study.
Other comments?
Representative Corman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I actually would like to see further study on batteries.
I think that they are going to be key toward getting the three re's for energy, renewable, reliable, and reasonably priced.
I had a conversation with Jim Andrews, president of Granite Shore Power, who we all saw at the summit a couple of weeks ago but I had a a conversation with him offline and there what they're looking to do is actually use batteries not for long-term storage but uh at Schiller and Merrimack what they plan to do is load up the batteries when energy is less expensive and then discharge the batteries into the grid at peak times which will actually be a great thing to do right they they make money doing it and it actually does the peak shaving which we all want to see in addition as you may know there's a project now in maine for 8.5 gigawatt hours of long-term storage.
Form Energy has a contract there.
And as we learned at the summit, Form Energy actually has a factory now in West Virginia.
They're actually building these things.
This is real.
So I think what we're going to see is that these batteries of the future are now going to be batteries of the present.
And another thing that we need to look at is how that's going to affect markets.
So when there is long-term storage, how is that going to affect electricity markets?
when Granite Shore Power is able to buy energy low and then sell it uh during peak times how is that going to affect market and is that something that the state needs to really get involved in we should at least understand it and that's one reason why i feel like this bill would be worth further study um Maybe not in the exact form, but the concept behind the bill.
Additional comments, Representative Harrington.
Yeah, you know, as I just mentioned, when the state gets involved in markets, it generally screws things up.
We just cost the rate pay is $160 million by forcing Eversource, basically, there was a lot of political pressure, sign this contract and forcing the PUC to approve it.
I was not on the PUC when that occurred, just for the record.
I don't think we need to encourage this type or that type or anything else.
A study by the Department of Energy in New Hampshire is going to be almost meaningless.
I'm sure there's millions of federal dollars out there because they're throwing money at anything that remotely can produce energy at all.
So us spending a quarter of a million dollars to do some study on batteries isn't going to make people put in more batteries or less batteries.
As was stated, there's at least two projects in New Hampshire that are going forward now without any study.
If they operate successfully and they are financially viable, I'm sure there'll be more of them.
And no matter what our study came out with, that's going to be the determining factor.
Do the ones that have been put in work?
And if they do work, do they make money?
There'll be more of them.
We don't need to waste a quarter of a million dollars by doing some analysis.
I agree that we don't need to burden our DOE with a study of this nature.
Representative Noel?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just wanted to say that we have, in Berlin, we have Brookfield Renewable, and they have a 16-plus megawatt battery installation there.
And they are putting that on the transmission system.
And it's been in service for not quite a year yet and is one of multiple facilities that they have invested in.
They have two, one in Millinocket in Maine, and they're planning another one in lewiston they're probably in the process of uh installing it uh they find it economic to do this uh they're located on a hydro plant so they have renewable power to to charge it uh but i believe they're making their money on voltage regulation and not so much on the battery backup capacity.
That's good information.
Representative Reynolds.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Yeah, I think I just want to support my colleagues' comments in supporting further that this legislation and type of study should go forward.
I think it's incumbent on all of us individually and incumbent on us collectively as a committee to understand as best we can the emerging trends in the energy market.
And clearly, long-term or utility-scale storage is one of them.
I don't think the study, you know, the emphasis of the study ought not be, you know, it's not for us to get into the nitty-gritty of the technology, how it works, or what's viable and what's not, or necessarily the finances, but rather what are the, we have to understand those things such that we understand what policy instruments might, are available, could be used to facilitate this.
And I just have to point out, Mr.
Chairman, your comments about one of the problems that you see with batteries, that they're expensive, but they sit idle much of the time.
It strikes me that that characterization could be applied to peaking power plants, which we certainly have had around in New Hampshire and which are supported by rates.
So, you know, batteries are the next thing to replace peaking power plants.
So how do we facilitate the transition?
So I think we should go forward with the study.
Further comments?
Representative Munns.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I find myself in the very uncomfortable position of agreeing with Representative Corman and Representative Harrington.
I do believe that, you know, we can hope.
I do agree that we need to encourage the adoption of batteries more in the state for all the reasons that Representative Corman proposed.
but I also agree that I'm not sure that an additional study is going to do anything because quite frankly, we had a very similar study requirement on the books in 2022 that was supposed to have been completed by 2024, and it was not.
And that's, I think, why this bill was introduced was to try to get that going again.
So I, I asked, I would ask the question, what, what makes us think that this is going to be any different than in the past?
And the other thing, to the point that you made, Mr.
Chair, about just the drafting or wording of the bill, There are some other issues with the drafting.
In lines 19 and lines 21, it makes reference to a, quote, a program, but it doesn't define what that program is.
In the previous legislation, it referred to what that program was.
So we would need to change the wording of this bill to be more accurate.
So bottom line, I guess I'm not sure what an additional study is going to do.
Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I printed out the Senate report on the consent calendar.
They voted 5-0 in favor of passing the bill.
And they basically state that the bill incorporates an added storage requirement proposing to leverage energy storage during peak usage, an approach that seeks to reduce reliance on the transmission lines to mitigate those associated costs.
And I think we tend to speak about costs from our own viewpoint, but the reality is that once the risk and the investment of putting in batteries around the state or in different areas, once they come online, they end up being used not only to increase reliability for the distribution grid in getting power from where it needs to go to where it's being used, but it also does mitigate that transmission expense, which New Hampshire currently picks up an inordinate amount of that expense because we haven't invested as much as our fellow states in the region and on the regional grid in terms of our dependence on the transmission line.
So I think it does warrant study because as a state, we kind of are responsible for whether or not the distribution grid within our borders is actually functioning properly.
And there are a lot of issues concerning the phasing of electrons on and off the system that we are not addressing and that are not in our plans, that we're not asking DOE to look at.
And battery storage is just one component of that.
But I don't think we get a pass on it.
I think it's something that even if we're not going to institute something for a year or two years or three years, I don't think we can avoid trying to learn to understand what it means for the state and the state's distribution system.
This bill doesn't mention distribution or transmission anywhere.
Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I was just going to say that I happen to agree with Representative Munns, who agrees with Representative Harrington, as well as Representative Quirman.
I think now is not the time to be spending a quarter million dollars on a study that on things that are already happening in the state.
And I don't know if the Department of Energy would add anything else to to this particular study.
So at this time, I would be opposed to going forward with any legislation on this matter.
So are you making a motion to that effect?
So moved.
I make a motion.
Second.
So it's moved and seconded.
Let's take a straw vote.
And remember, this is not binding.
You can change your mind at executive session, but let's take a straw vote.
All those in favor of the motion to not recommend this bill for future legislation?
Okay, nine.
All those who would vote the other way?
Five.
Nine to five.
And remember, as I said, it's non-binding, so you can change your mind.
Okay, so that's the fifth and final bill.
Does anyone have anything that they would like to add to this work session?
Any comments?
Representative Harrington.
Yeah, I actually had two things, but I'll save the other one for executive session because it's a little bit more germane.
I just wanted to let people know if they're not aware of what's going on with nuclear power.
There's been a couple of really potentially very, very large events.
One is Microsoft has signed up with a nuclear plant for $109 a megawatt to buy 100% of their output for 20 years.
Three Mile Island.
But the problem, of course, is to restart Three Mile Island.
And also, Holtec has been awarded all total, the money and loans is $3.1 billion to restart the plant out in Michigan.
They had bought the plant to decommission it, and now they've decided to put it back online.
They got a loan for $1.2 billion, and then the rural electorate co-ops that the plant would service got a grant for another one point something billion dollars.
So altogether, it's over three billion.
And again, they're looking to restart those plants.
So depending on how that process works, that may not be the last of these we see.
But, you know, just sort of don't hold your breath because you've got those two major issues, the interconnection, but and also the NRC, which is not known for super efficiency, especially when they have to write new first time rules.
So but it is a step towards bringing more nuclear power back online.
And the fact they're willing to pay $109 a megawatt hour, I guess, is that they're really interested in reliability over cost because that's quite a bit higher than most contracts.
Representative Munns.
I'm glad Representative Harrington brought that up because I think what it does is it highlights one of the impacts of artificial intelligence because that's why Microsoft is buying the power, is to drive their artificial intelligence that, um, um, because that's why Microsoft is buying the power is to drive their artificial intelligence business.
Um, and, um, I'm, I'm hoping that, um, you know, as we move forward next year, that, um, we can spend, um, some more time talking about artificial intelligence and what it means on not only the power markets, but just generally, because it's having a major impact.
Yeah, but I think we could probably bring some other people in.
I think that really needs to be a focus for those of us that are going to be returning.
I think that really needs to be a major focus of what we look at going forward, because it has big impacts.
Other comments?
Representative McGee?
I just wanted to let Representative Harrington and anyone else know that doesn't know this, but the U.S.
legislature, Congress, hasn't passed very much this year, but one thing they did pass on a bipartisan basis was the Advance Act, which was basically about nuclear power and trying to remove the red tape and the expense that that red tape entails for people trying to invest in next generation plants.
So I haven't read all of the details of the Advance Act, but it is focused expressly at making sure that if that is one of the choices that is not contributing to warming, that people are able to do it without the incredible red tape that we've put in the way.
Yeah, I'm familiar with it.
There was a big article in Nuclear News about it, but I've just, I've been one of these guys with the NRC, having had years of experience with them.
I'll believe it when I see it.
Any additional comments?
All right.
Oh, Representative Summers.
Sorry, since we're on this committee and we're being kind of techie right now.
I just wanted to push out there that one thing will be coming up in the next term over the next two years is dealing with the security of qubits and qubits are, if you don't know it right now, all security, even our federal government uses what's called RSA, RSA tokens, which right now with a normal processor, it would take you tens to hundreds of years to be able to resolve a password or break a password to get in.
By using quantum computing with qubits, you now can do it in several hours.
So there's going to be a huge push over the next year to two years to try to find some remedy with quantum computing, which is going to require more electricity, as Representative Harrington said, to be able to come up with some way to stop folks being able to use quantum computing to be able to break into all of our security that we have worldwide.
Yes, cybersecurity is a huge problem.
George Will wrote a column in the Sunday Union Leader about cybersecurity issues just this past Sunday.
Any further comments?
All right, let's go get lunch and be back here at 1 o'clock to take up these executive session bills, interim study bills, and be thinking about which bills you would like to write the report for.
Republicans will stay in this room for a quick caucus.
Thank you.
Okay, everybody, let's get started.
I'd like to open an executive session on our five retained bills.
We will take them in the order they appear in the calendar.
We had a work session on all five bills earlier today.
We took straw votes to indicate what we might want to do, and that will probably predict the outcome of our deliberations on these five bills, but nothing's a guarantee because those straw votes were not binding.
So we'll start by opening an exact session on HB 509 relative to phasing out the minimum electric renewable portfolio standard, and I'll recognize Representative Harrington for a motion.
Yeah, I move for additional legislation study on HB 509 and the subject included in it.
Representative Thomas.
Second.
Moved and seconded that we recommend HB 509 for additional legislation.
Any discussion?
Representative Harrington.
Well, I might get pretty quick because I said everything I needed to say this morning but basically this phases it out over five years the renewable portfolio standard I think everybody in New Hampshire is well educated on climate change and global warming we've been constantly told about it for going on 15 years if not longer now and it's I think time to say the people of New Hampshire are smart enough to make a decision for themselves on what type of electricity to buy.
This bill would also reinstate the rule that was suspended that says the utilities have to provide renewable energy up to 100% if requested by a customer.
The customer would have to pay any additional costs associated with that.
So the options there, either through the utility or through a competitive supplier, anybody that wants to can go out and get all types of any type of power they're looking for.
And there's no need for the state to come in and say, you're not smart enough to make this decision for yourself, so we're going to make it for you.
Like I said, we don't tell people they have to buy a certain percentage of their produce being organic, or a certain percentage of their milk be skim milk.
I think people are smart enough to make this decision for themselves.
Representative McGee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
When we discussed this in the work session, we did, you know, none of the votes matter, but it was a 10-4 for do not recommend for further legislation, just so I can remind everybody what the discussion was.
No one's talking about whether or not people are smart enough to make their own decisions, as was discussed in that session.
We have people and businesses that are already, you know, reliant on the RPS credits, on the REC system, and we should not be disrupting that system if we don't even know what kind of effect it's going to have on the infrastructure that we have here.
And that was what the conversation was in the work session, is that we don't have a sense of what phasing out the RPS at this point would actually entail in terms of financial impacts to those businesses.
We have a lot of infrastructure that has been converted in towns and municipalities to pellet burners.
There are people who've invested in infrastructure, yeah, in solar.
We also have hydro plants plants we also have biomass infrastructure and we don't have any assessment of what kind of impact there would be if we started phasing down support for this program so i i just i don't think it makes sense for us to recommend that this bill anyway or the language in this bill about phasing out the RPS is something that should move forward.
I think that's why we sent it to IS in the first place, if I recall.
Okay, can we move now to a vote?
We've had a statement on both sides of this issue.
So I'd ask the clerk to call the roll on the question of recommend for future legislation on house bill 509.
Vice chair, Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Nauter.
Representative Harrington.
Yes.
Representative Brezhne.
Representative Bernardi, yes.
Representative Plosje.
No.
Representative Summers.
Yes.
Representative McGee.
No.
Representative Williams.
Representative Horgan.
No.
Representative Kaplan.
No.ns No Representative Noel No Representative Gallagher No Representative Corman No Representative Reynolds No Chairman Vose Yes One, two, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 7 to 10.
Okay.
By a vote of 7 to 10, the motion fails.
So the only other possible motion would have to be judged the motion that we will go forward with, which is not recommended for future legislation by a vote of 10 to 7.
Does the committee feel comfortable with making that assumption without taking a vote?
That's fine with me.
Okay.
So HB 509 is not recommended for future legislation by a vote of 10 to 7.
I need a volunteer to write the calendar report.
Representative McWilliams will write the calendar report.
When is it due?
How about Thursday?
Sounds good.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
So let's close that exec session and now open an exec session on House Bill 1398 relative to utility costs, utility recovery rather of costs associated with net energy metering.
I will make a motion to recommend for future legislation and recognize Representative Thomas.
Second.
Moved and seconded.
I'll make the quick point that recovering utility costs, I mean, net energy metering costs through stranded cost recovery is a mechanism that's been approved by the Public Utilities Commission and is currently used by the largest utility in the state, Eversource, and could be useful if the other utilities in the state used it as well for the purposes of tracking and transparency of net renewing costs.
Further discussion, Representative McGee.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
The point I'll bring up is one that came up in our work session about how allowing utilities to recover this money across customers, all customers, kind of democratizes their costs for default service.
But it doesn't allow the same for anyone else that's in that business.
So it does create a disadvantage.
And I think since net metering in general is being looked at in a rate case over at the Public Utilities Commission now, this is not something we should be inserting as a change into the system.
Again, it's based on the economics, which I don't think we have a full understanding of, and I don't think we had testimony on.
So I think it's premature.
Okay, we have a statement, pro and con, can we take a vote?
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on the question of recommend for future legislation on House Bill 1398.
Vice Chair Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Nauter.
Representative Harrington.
No.
Representative Brezhne.
Yes.
Representative Nodder.
Representative Harrington.
No.
Representative Brezhne.
Yes.
Representative Bernardi.
Representative Plosier.
Yes.
Representative Summers.
Representative McGee.
No.
Representative McWilliams.
Representative Horgan.
No.
Thank you.
mcgee no representative mcwilliams no uh representative horgan no representative kaplan no representative munns no representative noel no representative gallagher no representative Corman no representative Reynolds no chairman Gallagher?
No.
Representative Corman?
Representative Reynolds?
No.
Chairman Vose?
Yes.
Same 7 to 10.
Okay.
The vote on the motion to recommend for future legislation fails with a of 7 to 10, which makes the default a recommendation of not recommended for future legislation by a vote of 10 to 7.
And I will volunteer to write the calendar report for HB 1398.
So we'll close that executive session and now open the executive session on HB 1508, requiring fiber optic communication service providers to prioritize service restoration for public safety and public health organizations and recognize Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
on hb 1508 i my motion is to recommend for further legislation recognize representative bernardi second that motion moved and seconded that we recommend hb 508 for additional legislation representative thomas yes thank you mr chair Realizing that we're dealing with a private company here, we have a situation where a first responder was unable to get satisfaction to restore his communication system anywhere near in a reasonable time despite repeated efforts contacting the company in question he received no satisfaction whatsoever and with the point that bothers me the most is that when he went to get other help from the state the state said sorry we're just not authorized to deal with anything like that because you're dealing with a private company I believe this bill properly written because as it's written now, it's just too vague, properly written could emphasize the importance of any company dealing with communications involving first responders to either be more responsive or in some way facilitate them to put the system back into order again.
I believe future legislation, which we don't want to require anything in one sense, but maybe in a sense wording something that makes it very clear to companies that if they're dealing with first responders that they must prioritize in some way getting the first responders' communications back up to speed, I think has some merit and probably bears further investigation.
Representative Harrington.
Yeah, as I said this morning, I think the major problem with this is I don't think we have jurisdiction.
From my days at the PUC, the FCC made it pretty clear that, for example, with phones, once you went from, say, Verizon to a cable company providing voice over IP, that the state PUCs no longer had any jurisdiction.
I don't think we have any jurisdiction over fiber optic or cable providers, even though I think the bill just says fiber optic.
I'm assuming it would be extended to internet providers in general.
So if we have no jurisdiction, we really can't pass a law telling them what to do.
So I think this is at least until we determine from a legal point of view that we have some authority.
I can't see Pat trying to pass a bill.
Any further discussion?
Yes, Representative Corman.
Thank you.
Yeah, I won't be voting for this.
I really feel like this is the responsibility of the first responder to have a backup system, and it shouldn't be that hard.
We're talking low bandwidth communication.
We're not talking anything really fancy here, and I really feel like this is on the first responder of this particular incident.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none, I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on the question of recommend for future legislation on House Bill 1508.
Thank you.
Lysher Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Nodder.
Representative Harrington.
No.
Representative Brezhne.
Representative Bernardi.
Yes.
Representative Plosje.
No.
Representative Bernardi, yes.
Representative Ploget.
No.
Representative Summers.
Representative McGee.
Yes.
Representative McWilliams.
Representative Horgan.
Yes.
Representative Kaplan.
No.
Representative Munns.
Representative Noel.
yes representative kaplan no representative munns no representative noelle yes representative gallagher yes representative corman no representative reynolds no chairman vose no One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
By a vote of eight to nine, the motion to recommend fails, making the default recommendation not recommended for future legislation.
And I need someone to write a calendar report for this particular piece of legislation.
Okay, Representative Harrington.
Representative Hington will write the calendar report.
I need it by Thursday, Mike.
And that concludes the exec session on House Bill 1508.
So next up would be to open an exec session on House Bill 1617FN relative to energy procurement agreements for default service.
And the chair recognizes Representative Bernardi.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I recommend not recommended for future legislation.
Representative Thomas.
Second.
Moved and seconded that we not recommend this for future legislation.
Representative Bernardi.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
As was discussed in our earlier session, work session, this issue is already being addressed by PUC and DOE, and therefore, we don't need to stick our oar further in the water.
Further discussion?
Seeing none, I'll ask Clerk to call the roll on the question of not recommend for future legislation, House Bill 1617.
Vice Chair Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Nodder.
Representative Harrington.
Yes.
Representative Brezhne.
Representative Bernardi.
Yes.
Representative Ploge.
Representative Summers.
Yes.
Representative McGee.
Representative McWilliams.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Representative Kaplan.
Yes.
Representative Munns.
Representative Noel.
Yes.
Representative Kaplan.
Representative Munns.
Yes.
Representative Noel.
Representative Gallagher.
Yes.
Representative Corman.
Representative Reynolds.
Yes.
Chairman Bowes.
17 to 0.
We vote to not recommend this bill for future legislation.
And Representative Bernardi, you will write the House calendar report, correct?
Yes.
Thank you.
Close the executive session on House Bill 1617 and move to our last bill.
Open an exec session on Senate Bill 540 and recognize Representative Thomas.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I make motion to not recommend it for further legislative action.
Representative Bernardi.
Second that motion.
Moved and seconded that we judge Senate Bill 540 to be not worthy of recommendation for future legislation representative thomas thank you mr chair uh during uh work session it was clearly displayed that there are several uh institutions you know using batteries right now information that might be gleaned from a from a study, especially from the Department of Energy here in New Hampshire, and spending over a quarter million dollars to do such a study on things that are already being done seems to be of no significant benefit at this time, which is why I chose not to recommend for further action.
Representative Corman.
Representative Reynolds, you have your bank on.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Just to repeat some of the points I made earlier, we are finding that batteries are going to be significant game changers in the markets and in how energy is distributed and at what time and the impacts on transmission.
This particular bill also does call for study of behind the meter, so it's not entirely utility scale.
And I think we're going to start seeing some impacts of behind the meter as well.
I myself have batteries and that has actually changed my energy profile.
So I do think this is worth study.
I understand Representative Thomas's point about spending money on it, but in the scheme of things, it's not that much money.
We're spending that much to extend the 603 area code.
This seems like something that we should be getting ahead of and understanding because it is going to affect markets.
And with all due respect to Representative Harrington's points about that, when government puts the thumb on the markets, the markets get screwed up.
That doesn't mean that we shouldn't understand them.
And I think we should understand them.
Live free or die in the 603.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none, I'll ask the clerk to call the question of not recommending Senate Bill 540 for future legislation.
Vice Chair Thomas.
Yes.
Representative Nodder.
Representative Harrington.
Yes.
Representative Brezhne.
Representative Bernardi.
Yes.
Representative Plosje.
Representative Summers.
Yes.
Representative McGee.
No.
Representative McWilliams.
Representative McGee.
No.
Representative McWilliams.
Representative Horrigan.
No.
Representative Kaplan.
Representative Munns.
No.
Representative Noelle.
Representative Gallagher.
No.
Representative Corman.
Representative Reynolds.
No.
Chairman Vose?
Yes.
8 to 9.
By a vote of 8 to 9, the recommendation of recommend, no, the recommend is defeated.
So the recommendation will be recommend by default.
And the vote is 9 to 8.
And Representative Corman will write the report for the calendar.
So with that, we'll close that executive session and complete our activity for the day by recognizing Representative Harrington, who would like to discuss an issue that we should all be aware of, will probably be a significant topic in the new session.
Yeah, I'm not sure if everyone caught it, but there's a project that Eversource is running right now.
This is a New England-wide issue.
It's called asset conditioning.
That's the term.
I don't know where they came up with it, but it basically means refurbishing existing transmission.
The cost is going to be in the billions of dollars.
There's a present project being done now in New Hampshire for $400 million, and it came in front of the Site Evaluation Committee, and I think the consumer advocate or someone like him tried to bring up was it really needed and why was it costing so much, and they basically said they had no standing in the committee and were asked to leave.
They were correct because the site evaluation committee does not look at cost, does not look at need.
The idea is if somebody wants to build a whatever 40 megawatt power plant, the question is, does it comply with all of New Hampshire's siting laws, not whether the power plant is necessary or if it's expensive or not too inexpensive.
The problem with the transmission is, as my friend from Rhode Island coined the phrase, transmission is the largest unregulated monopoly in the United States.
And I checked with Nesco on this, New England States Committee on Electricity, or the New England, whatever it is, New England States Committee on Electricity, and that represents all six of the states.
They've put this as their number one issue and their report to all six New England, whatever it is, New England State's Community on Electricity, and that represents all six of the states.
They've put this as their number one issue to the, and their report to all six New England governors for this year, saying that this was going to be billions of dollars and it's not looked at by anybody.
According to the people at Nesco, they even checked with FERC, who would have jurisdiction over transmission, and they were told, if you send something down to us, we don't have anyone to look at it anyways.
So basically, there is no one looking at this.
And as much as I believe in free markets, this isn't a free market, it's a monopoly.
So if it's a monopoly, it needs to be regulated.
And we have to look at a way of doing that.
What I'm going to be proposing, and I'm not sure how far this will get, but the Site Evaluation Committee statute would be changed so that for a project that where the cost and need are not reviewed by another state or federal agency, the Site Evaluation Committee will take those facts into consideration granting a certificate.
So if they can't show that this is the most efficient way to do it, then the site evaluation committee could say, well, we're not going to give you a certificate until you do that.
I'm sure the utilities are going to fight like hell, but I think, again, this is billions of dollars.
And I don't know how many people have been looked at transmission projects in the past.
They have gotten better, but historically they would run somewhere in the vicinity of 100% cost overruns.
That was like automatic when they put new transmission projects in.
They'd say, well, this is going to cost $300 million.
It would come back at $600 million.
This is going to cost $700 million.
It would come back at $1.4 billion.
And by ISO rules applied by FERC, that's acceptable.
Up to 200% over the cost is within their range, minus 50% plus 200%.
I don't know how they come up with those numbers, but they did.
So I just think it's important that we try to look at this and say, you know, at least from New Hampshire's point of view, you're going to have to make some attempt to show that this is necessary and that you're being cost effective in doing it.
Because right now, no one's looking at anything, literally.
And like I say, it's going to be billions of dollars.
If you look at that, find out more about it, you can check out the NESCO report to the New England governors.
I think it was issued in July or something like that.
Just wanted to get people to be aware of that.
There is a current asset condition project before the Site Evaluation Committee right now.
It's a $400 million project, and the state of New Hampshire's share of that project will be $40 million.
So that'll be added to transmission costs once the project is completed.
Eversource wants to replace wooden transmission towers in a 60-mile stretch of the transmission corridor with metal transmission towers.
And they want to upgrade the wire to fiber optic wire.
So it's going to be a very expensive project.
If legislation submitted for the 2025 session were to pass, it would not affect this project.
This project would go forward regardless.
So we're going to get stuck with those costs no matter what.
But the question is, how do we provide oversight to future projects that want to upgrade transmission?
So that's the important question here.
And one other thing just to emphasize, because this project's in New Hampshire, it really doesn't make any difference to us.
If it's in New England, so if they're doing it in Connecticut, we're still going to get 10% of the bill.
So we can't control anything that happens in the other states.
Maybe if we can get this through, the will join in but this is not just okay it's done in new hampshire forget about it because they do it in maine they do it massachusetts we're still going to get a bill for it representative mcgee yeah just a thought um i was thinking about this recently there's a lot of changes going on trying to work on grid reliability and upgrades.
And I know, you know, grid reliability is something that we're going to pay for one way or another.
But it struck me that this committee and the state in general has very little insight into those investments in terms of what we get for it and how long it will last us because technology is ever-changing.
And sometimes when investments are made in the state infrastructure, we're not really sure how long that gets amortized over, when it's going to need to be fixed again, or what we're getting, basically.
We don't have those conversations.
So to Representative Harrington's point, we probably should have some changes in statutory language in terms of what we look at, when we look at it, because after the fact, then it's a stranded cost and everybody's going to pay for it.
but beforehand if we at least understand what we're getting for the money it might be more helpful because what seems to happen is as soon as one large cost gets approved, the next large cost is in the queue.
And so, you know, I wish we had a more of a planning perspective around the grid and transmission and distribution in the state, because I think that's the only way to really get a handle on costs, but that's just me.
Okay, I want to bring everybody up to date on one other topic you might find interesting.
I'm currently chairing a commission to study the assessing of power generation.
It's been a very difficult and contentious subject in our state, because we have the Department of Revenue Administration assessing generation plants for the utility property tax.
And then we have municipal assessors assessing plants for the swept tax, statewide education property tax.
And those two numbers are frequently extremely different.
And this has led to a plethora of lawsuits.
And the people who pay for those lawsuits are you and I, both as ratepayers on the utility side and taxpayers on the municipal side.
So our commission has been, this is the third iteration of this commission, and we have been studying a solution to this problem.
And I'm relatively certain, although we still have three or four more meetings before we generate a report, we've already had four meetings.
But I'm relatively certain that we're going to submit legislation to remove generation from the utility property tax.
And that will remove the DRA from the equation.
So the only assessing of power plants will be done by assessors hired by municipalities.
So removing that contention between these two different evaluations should significantly reduce lawsuits and litigation.
It won't completely eliminate it, but it'll reduce it.
The points of contention that we're wrestling with right now is whether we should require the utilities to do some kind of reporting on their business income.
We don't require that of other manufacturers.
And if you consider a utility to be a manufacturer of electricity, then the question is, should we require them to report on the value of what they produce and use that in the assessing process?
That currently happens, but the generators say that it shouldn't happen going forward.
The other issue we're wrestling with a little bit is equalization, because a generation plant, unlike a house, doesn't change value up and down like houses do.
Its value is pretty steady throughout its lifetime.
So we're trying to figure out how to use, how to modify legislation about equalization so that the power generators don't have to be subject to ebbs and flows in the value of their asset based on equalization.
But we will have a report by November 1st, and hopefully I think we have a solution going forward so we won't have to study this issue any further.
So that's my report on that commission.
We meet Tuesday mornings at nine o'clock at the Department of Revenue and Administration off Pleasant Street.
You're welcome to attend if you like.
Representative Munns serves on that committee with myself and two members of Ways and Means and two members of Municipal and County, plus a bunch of industry folks.
So that's my update on that.
Anybody else have any updates on commissions they're serving on?
Representative Thomas.
Just to know that we'll be having our first meeting of the new session.
I sit on the commission for determining alternative measures, alternative methods for road toll tax.
And we'll be meeting tomorrow to, we've met before, but in the previous biennium.
And so this is the first one one this year and we'll be meeting again to discuss you know i think i've heard just about every possible uh method so far i even attended ncsl where they had a special seminar on the same subject and the only thing i knew i i heard at that seminar was something that maine is looking at doing which is establishing some sort of a special road lane to have for EVs, and they maybe pay a special fee to drive in that lane.
I didn't quite catch it all because I had to arrive late there, but that was the only new thing I heard.
But we'll discuss it tomorrow and see what it brings.
We're still trying to get our hands around a new paradigm as we move forward with this new technology.
Does that commission or committee have to have a report this year?
We haven't had a meeting yet, so I didn't look at the details, but I'll find out tomorrow.
I don't know.
The answer is I don't know.
It seems like it should because it's the first one they've met, and it's near the end of the year so but i don't know well there's not much time to no produce a report what's there usually do around november 1st representative herrington yeah just one other thing i'm not officially on the on this commission but i've been following it closely because i was on it 20 years ago and the situation really hasn't gotten much better.
This is on dams in New Hampshire.
There's about a hundred million dollars worth of repairs needed to dams and I think you've probably heard like I think it was earlier this summer, the spring, they were talking about tearing down a dam in the Manchester area someplace which would effectively turn was a hundred acre lake into a stream with a lot of mud and they some guy on TV, and he was saying about how he just put in a $15,000 dock and so forth.
Part of the problems is the hydroelectric dams, when their license gets renewed, they're required to put in a fish ladder.
And a lot of them look at that and say, it's not worth the cost to put it in.
I don't make enough money to cover it.
So once they leave, they no longer maintain maintenance on the dam.
So the commission is looking at two possible funding mechanisms because the money's going to come from someplace.
And, you know, the obvious, maybe too obvious solution is, well, let's just charge the people who have the waterfront property because they get the advantage of them.
But having waterfront property makes a huge difference in their tax bill.
So if the dam were to go away on a lake, you know, a house that's worth a million dollars may only be worth a half a million.
So the first thing they're going to do is file for reduction in property taxes.
So since generally spending doesn't go down, everyone else's taxes are going to go up.
So we're trying to look at some way of making it a little bit more equitable.
One thing it may be is a shoreline assessment fee, and the other thing looking at it is a boat registration fee.
So you may hear on both of those, because everybody that puts a boat in a lake in New Hampshire generally is in a lake with a dam.
So just a heads up.
Representative McGee?
Thanks, Mr.
Chairman.
Yeah, I was just reading that we still have about 300 million, 300 and something million in ARPA funds that haven't been totally spent.
And that one of the five things that you could focus on in your state was water infrastructure.
They understand that a lot of states have aging infrastructure.
And it's not just for cities and towns.
It's also for culverts.
And, you know, basically, you know, as we saw with the floods that we had last December, you know, flooding infrastructure.
So I think, you know, that would be a logical place to take the money from if there needs to be repairs, because it's pretty hard to make individuals pick up that cost.
It'd probably be, like you said, $100 million is a lot of money.
But I'd look at that.
Representative Plosje.
Thank you, Chair.
Another committee, Representative Bresni and I are on, is, I have to look this up, Committee to Study the Feasibility and Impact of a New Hampshire Clean Energy Community Resilience and conservation corps.
That was, I believe, House Bill 1499.
We have three more meetings before a report is due on November 1st.
Okay, good.
Anything else?
Representative Thomas.
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
Well, this is the last meeting of this committee, and so I would like to thank all committee members that we know will not be coming back next time, and I'd like to thank those committee members that may or may not come back next time, and to congratulate everyone for a fine session of good discussions, good civil discussions.
We enjoyed it very much, and I appreciate all the work that was being done, and I wish best wishes to all of those, whether you're back here or not next year.
Representative McWilliams.
Thank you, Representative Thomas.
I appreciate your kind remarks.
As a six-year member of this committee, I just wanted to look around and acknowledge everyone that I've been able to work with for the last six years.
It's been an honor.
I'll miss you, and the work continues, so I appreciate everything that you have put in to do good things for our state's energy policy, and I look forward to seeing more good things from you in the future.
Thank you.
It's been an honor.
And we thank you for your service on this committee.
You've added immeasurably to our deliberations and discussions, and we appreciate it.
And we wish you well in the future, and we expect we'll probably see you back here at some point.
Anything else?
Representative McGee.
I'd just like to thank our subs again for coming in.
We know this is a busy time of year, so we really appreciate you taking the time.
Yes, thank you very much to both of you.
And also, I'd like to commend Chairman Bowes for doing an excellent job as our chairman the last two years.
That's very kind.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
So I guess we're done.
So everybody, good luck with your reelection campaigns, if you have one.
And we'll see you when we see you.
We'll see you on Veto Day this Thursday, I suspect.
So have a pleasant evening.
Thank you.